madam chair good morning it is such a
pleasure to be able to recognize you
here on International Women's Day
setting an example for other women to
follow and furthermore setting an
example in public service which we know
this country so desperately needs thanks
for having me good to be here let's
begin here regulating Wall Street is a
key issue on the campaign trail what's
at stake for the SEC in the selection I
think what you want the SEC to be always
since nineteen thirty-four since its
founding is that very strong independent
agency where you have not only an expert
career staff but commissioners who are
dedicated to its mission and so you know
I have confidence that will happen
throughout they don't think that's a
risk with the outcome in any in any of
two directions I I think appointments
are extremely important but I think
historically you've seen the seriousness
brought to bear on those appointments
that it deserves given the function of
the SEC well you've accomplished a great
deal in your three years as chair of the
SEC record numbers I mean some of that
is clearly untouchable right record
numbers of enforcement actions billions
of dollars collected in fines and
penalties but you've also enacted rules
that remain unpopular on Wall Street
would you not expect say hypothetically
speaking at Donald Trump or Ted Cruz to
want to reverse undo or perhaps even got
some of that well look I mean I think
it's always an evolving landscape in
terms of what's optimal regulation
including watching what their impacts
are as they go forward so you want
attention to rule makings going forward
but nobody wants to relive the financial
crisis and many many of those rules that
the agency is executed on other agencies
of execute on are really they have
really made us much more resilient to
that as a market structure as a
financial system and nobody should want
to undo that so it to understand what
you're saying if we were to roll back
some of what the SEC and other agencies
have done you believe we would be
exposing financial markets to uh greater
potential for another Christ without
question without question
how about what the SEC gets from the
left and not just from the right there's
criticism on both sides does the
politicization of the agency and
regulation more broadly speaking make it
harder for you to do your job and make
it harder for the next sec chair to do
his or her job like I think the
criticism from all directions comes with
the territory I mean it's and the SEC in
particular in its policymaking
particularly I would say it has touches
very important industries investors
everyone else and about fifty percent of
what you do is going to be disliked by
everybody won't be the same fifty
percent every time and so the key for
the SEC is to fulfill its mission as an
independent agency and I think it
doesn't very well I mean you keep you
know irrespective of political party you
come into that agency with a mission to
fulfill and that is not to be
politicized madam chair the clock is
ticking on this administration investors
and the financial services industry
furthermore are waiting for the SEC to
take action on several fronts let's
start with market structure what can you
accomplish before there's another
president in the White House and
probably someone else running the sec I
think I think we've accomplished a great
deal already one of my highest
priorities even before I was confirmed
was really to focus on enhancing our
equity market structure and we've taken
a number of measures to date to do that
we've also set up the mechanism and the
energy to do really the first
comprehensive review of the equity
market structure in the agency's history
we have a market structure Advisory
Committee that's that's quite active in
getting more active we're taking on you
know all of the issues soup to nuts well
we also optimized some specific areas
that we can do more in the short term
late last year for example we proposed a
rule for greater transparency for 80
esas you know enormously important we'll
take some more measures throughout the
rest of this year and into the next
you've talked about the potential for
fundamental changes will that
comprehensive review be done while
you're the SEC chair and will we see
those fundamental changes put in place I
think some of them
you know maybe in the eye of the
beholder what's fundamental or not I
think any change that optimizes the
equity markets for investors and those
companies seeking to raise capital are
fundamental but this would this is a
review that will continue past this year
without any question if it's done right
it needs to be comprehensive and deal
with the most significant issues worst
thing you can do is to look at something
that superficially seems to make sense
but you don't have really the data to
justify going forward on it and you may
do more harm than good so it's not
something you want to rush but it's
something we certainly have major
traction on and will continue to what do
you think could or should be done to
improve in your terms the equity market
well I've talked about this that you
know at some length I mean in addition
to sort of the number the areas that
we're looking at whether it's a you know
conflict of interest the fee structures
you gotta look at the SRO structures and
whether that still makes sense or not
but there are also places to get greater
transparency for investors that are
enormously important not just 80 esas
but but also on what's that what happens
to your order how is it routed and you
know who gets paid what and who's
actually executing for you they're
getting best execution so all those
issues are enormously important and some
of that is wrapped up in concerns of
over high frequency trading the maker
taker model and specifically the pilot
program that the ACCC has talked about
starting text size pilot which you know
will will begin this year will begin
will begin while you're the charities
will begin while I'm cheerly suc very
pleased to see that getting launched
think it's very important you know and
the objective is obviously to get the
data to see whether you can increase
secondary liquidity for particularly
smaller businesses and so very happy to
get that done and it will it will it
will begin this year as well you know in
terms of high frequency trading I mean I
think it's you know again as with
probably most areas that we deal with
very important to sort of define one's
terms high frequency traders are not a
monolith they are they use lots of
different strategies you've seen studies
that talk about all the good that and
the benefits they yield to the market
some of the more aggressive liquidity
taking high frequency trading strategies
may be the opposite of that so we're
studying that very carefully if high
frequency traders engage in market
manipulation we continue to bring
enforcement cases as we would with any
market participant
again you know the automated markets and
the high-speed markets and the use of
algos is something it's not just high
frequency traders it's also
broker-dealers on behalf of
institutional investors use that lots of
benefits come with that but some risks
come with that that we have to be you
know constantly evaluating back in 2014
you promised a rule to address some of
those strategies and at the time you
described it as aggressive and
destabilizing has that been put in place
or is that's something that we have yet
to see while you're still the chair what
is on what is very actively ongoing is
the staff formulating a recommendation
on the anti disruptive trading rule
which is the one I talked about before
and that's essentially you know to deal
with periods of particular vulnerability
in the markets where some of these
aggressive liquidity taking strategies
may well be you know damaging to the
markets and investors so that's
something that we're pushing very hard
on this year okay more specifically on a
related point will you approve plans for
a consolidated audit trail the kind of
system that everybody needs to
understand what happened on during the
flash crash and more recently on August
the 24th that is certainly I think I
spoke about this a little while ago very
high priority to get that plan approved
this year and I expected the Commission
will actually act on a notice to get
noticing comment on that quite soon
actually how about a fiduciary standards
for financial advisors you know again
that's something that I think is
enormously important that every advisor
whatever their nomenclature I can call
it that whatever their regulatory regime
acts in the best interests of their
clients it is as I have said before and
we would do it under section 9 13 of
dodd-frank it is not a quick path the
SEC has been studying this because of
its complexities its importance its
difficulties you know for many many
years and I think it's enormously
important to proceed on proceed right on
and you know I certainly hope that we
see traction on it this year but I don't
want to create the impression that it's
you know it's something that's going to
secrecy not put it in place before you
leave I certainly hope it there's a
proposal this year the Labor Department
as you know is about to put its own
fiduciary standard in place for advisors
on retirement accounts is it not crazy
the brokers are going to have to operate
at some point in the not too distant
future under two sets of rules
regulating pretty much the same
well I mean again we are like government
not working coordination is very
important there's no question about that
you see it in then over-the-counter
derivatives space where we need to
coordinate with not only the CFTC but
international regulators to be at least
as compatible as we can be we don't have
identical market spaces and that's
certainly true with respect to a
fiduciary duty rule but we're
independent agencies with independent
you know statutory responsibilities
Department of Labor has the ERISA space
enormously important and even today you
know brokers who are in the ERISA space
are dealing with our rules and they're
dealing with the Labor Department's rule
so it's not a new phenomenon that there
may be different requirements in those
different spaces again once you try to
coordinate as much as you can madam
chair securities lawyers many of whom I
know you know well have no today marked
decrease in the SES use as he sees use
of administrative law courts over the
past year why has the agency been
turning more to federal courts to
adjudicate enforcement cases when your
success rate in administrative courts
has been so great well I mean again you
take a slice of the statistics in it but
if you look over time our success rate
is quite high in district court as well
as administrative proceedings last year
for example our record in district court
was a hundred percent actually and it
was not in administrative proceedings we
we lost some there you know but both
system Congress obviously set up the
administrative proceedings as an avenue
for us to protect investors in certain
kinds of cases we certainly want to use
that authority other federal agencies
use it to we use both you know evidence
we've tried to increase the transparency
of our choice process there the
Commission has to approve the venue
choice both systems are fair they're not
identical you get some rights and
administrative proceedings you do not
get in district court and I know that
from being a litigator at a trial lawyer
specifically well at least in a related
matter i guess it's related Justice
Scalia was very determined as you know
to narrow the scope of insider trading
prosecutions does his death and the
current vacancy on the Supreme Court tip
the scales in favor of regulators very
hard to judge that I wouldn't you know
try if I could that it's a survey you
know guess it what impact that may have
what we have done since the Newman
decision
and which as you know as a Second
Circuit decision in the chainsaw case
yes the one that it was actually a US
Attorney's Office case is obviously take
cognizant and cognizance of it it is an
important decision its impact has been
less I think on our enforcement on
insider trading cases than some of the
some of the commentators at least had
envisioned and so we've continued with a
very active insider trading program
enormously important to do that the
Supreme Court has taken cert as you know
on a Ninth Circuit case which will deal
with the personal benefit requirement
and that's a very important decision to
watch you again you're a former
prosecutor this is your wheelhouse do
you affect the death of Justice Scalia
to affect the outcome of that case can't
judge that really can't judge that I
mean that they're very there are a
number of different issues that that
could impact the thinking there I
wouldn't it fathom a gas even now madam
chair again recognizing all the
accomplishments you've had as chair of
the SEC and again on this international
women's day setting up blazing a trail
for other women to follow what you have
done and what you have done in concert
with other regulators I think it's fair
to say is attempt to change the culture
on wall street in the financial services
industry to what degree have you been
successful I think both we and I think
much of Wall Street has been
significantly successful but there is a
distance to go what's not to do well
changing culture is not an overnight or
even a five-year you know project I mean
what you find i think when you're trying
to change culture in particularly
significant ways as you change it at the
top they've been enormously successful
there you may even change it in the
trenches but you've got a big swath of
you know middle managers where you've
got to make sure the message is taken in
absorbed and lived basically so it's
it's a it's an evolving responsibility I
think on the part of not only the
regulators but also Wall Street and
Jerry thank you very much thank you
apply plenty with you here on this
international women's day